FIVEM  PRIMAO STATE
VE WHO
WAS ENDORSED, ONE OF
REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED TO IMPEACF
CHIGAN, ISD REFOR JOINING ME.WEN
E  DOND FOR HIS ACTIONS ON AND U
DO YOUHE CASE THE
RETE VOTERS AND IT
INDEPE
INDEPENDENTS?
EA
RI
CERTAIIS ECONOMY AND
PRICES, BUT I THK THERE'S BEEN
W, OBVIOU
DIFFERENT FAXES THAT ARE N
WE'LL SEE  INK IT'S HAD AN ON VC
THE COTES BEEN VER
RE DIVULGE A
DETAILS IN ACE OHEAR., U , OBVI
TH DAYS  IS THAT
SOME OF THVELKED WHO -- THEIARC.
Y AREN'T THEYING NOW A YEAR AND
HALF AGOLY TE Y WITNSED WHAT WA?
>> WEL CONSERVATIVE JU
ESHI
WEEK THAMP ARSTIR
AND PRESENT DA TO AMER
MEPRESIDENT EXPLORING 2024 RUN
AV FROM E  I THINK THAT DONALD
TRUMP  GO BE A CANDIDATE24.TILL.
WE SEE THAT RTIN AN. A NUMBER O
WINS WHERE HE'S ENDORSED
CANDIDATES TE WON.'S HAD A FEW
JORITY OF THE REPUBLICAN BASE
AND WILL HARD TO STOP.
L
E LOOK AS PRICES,
HAPPY WITH STRATIH  WHY H MEIE.
>> WHAT DO IY UTT WHAAVE SEEN
THAT REPUBLICAN , YOU
THINK, STIIGHTAKE
RUN? LOOK,S  WAS A CLOSE ELECTN
IT WAS CERTAINLY A CLOSE 20.VE
THAT ARE REALLY UPSET THAT T GO
TE I DONALD TRLOST HIS PRIMARY K
EANS THAT THE --
MENT, HALF WILL
RETURNING TO CONGRESS AREINGH
'23.TION W
T IN THE HOUSE
RE ARE
STAND UT TH BE.
FOCO, YOU MY
DISTRICT,  LOST A
NA  1TO 13, SO THEY MADA SAND
ME SCHOOL  L GA MY HOUSE.
DISTRICT UNG DICED HIS
ARE .AH, I THINK THER B
ALTHOUGH THERE WERE ONLY TEN OF
WERE 35 OFS  FOR A
BIPARTISAN COMMISSION TO LOOK AO
FOLKS WHO WERE, FRD , WHICIS TH
WELL.
SO, OUR GROUP IS
SENA.ID HAVE A MAJORITYF THEWHAH
SENATORS VOTE TO
PREST.SEW,  WHYOLITIC
WEW THINGS ALL
OUT.
STATE RED FLAG LAWS AND G TO L G
IMINATING TH
DO YOU THINK AEAL IS STILLTT>>
CHAIR OF THE BTIM
ER ZOOG LAST W
WITH A COUPLE OF SENATORS.
THEY BROUGHT US UP TO EE
KLOULD HEY WERE.
ISLATIVE,
SINCTH ALE A
WEOUENATE'S GOING
TO BT, AS E WILL BE ND OF THIS .
I'M HOPING THEY THICKING
POINTS.
SHOULD THEY GET THE VOTES TO GET
E, I TNKHOUSE AKE IT UME
COME .
HAVEN'T E IN THE
YOU KNOWOS
SENSE.ABIDING FOLKS SHOULDN'VE
ANY FEARS IN TMSON
IT'S BEEN  POINT
PARTICULARLY FOR THE A
T EIWEE ANLI CAS WOULDNEL
THEIR SECONDNDMENT RIGHTS
ARE BEINKEOT WHAT'S HAPPINHERE.
BUT IT'S BEEN ELEVATEDFOPARTICUR
N OR DAN CRENSHA